breasts the people who are out are
gathered around they're trying to see
who's gonna get the chicken dinner here
and by the way this is Nick's like fifth
game ever all right well there's nothing
more fun than go on a plane ride with
your Bros across the United States
that's what we're doing today we're
going to Tennessee for the 10-gig
festival it's a public festival where
anyone with the ticket can go and join
open play and see how well they do
hopefully you don't suck I've actually
losing every single game I played this
week in fact I've raged quit like three
times already this week so it's thinking
about trying to figure out a way to
practice on the plane flight leaves in
15 minutes we don't got your skirt yet
[Music]
I'm sorry the other day Jake called
asking the bucket help with a bill
course we are going to make some test
builds for a special effect versus
computer-generated it's practical the
effects being the actor coming out of
sand like a special forces agent coming
out of water so we're gonna make a few
little ones to test different fabrics
and membrane one we're going to make
little boxes stretch a fabric or plastic
over them cover them with sand and then
test it with our hands essentially
before we build to scale for the shoot
which would then instead of the hand for
the test it'll be a head coming through
so the first thing our uber driver told
us was get some barbecue that's funny
because Nick and myself were already
like okay where we gonna get barbecues
red sticky Pickers a riff house and
we're gonna do a pub G turned on after
this we're gonna like the gum up those
keyboards man and do this
gonna be a sauce outlet for the entire
match dude we've got all these barbecues
just like the best look at this the
anticipation level is incredibly high I
have a very special connection to ribs
when I was a kid my parents got me a
children's storybook can't over the name
it's a story about a young group of
cavemen and very specifically a cave boy
and their life on the plains and how
they had to live in prehistoric times
the cave boy and it's like caves sister
had to go out and hunt a wooly mammoth
and they take their little Spears and
they go out and they get this wooly
mammoth and what do they do with it well
they chop it up and they eat its ribs
that may be like an incredible
impression on me and so my childhood
consisted of going to every restaurant I
could and always ordering ribs on the
menu and always like channeling this
like little energy boy just clean it was
a total disaster for my parents because
they're like Jesus oh god he's getting
all dirty again with the ribs to this
day I still imagined myself being that
cave boy all right dude meat Cheers
now that I'm gonna be a father actually
I should probably track that book down I
have a little rib boy for myself dude
it's great city it's green I think the
biggest thing against LA is the fact
that there's no moisture there's dry its
dusty super hot coming from LA going
anywhere else suddenly you realize holy
pal there's trees everywhere there's
water it's vibrant and full of life
everywhere else it feels like it's the
10-gig festival here at the soldiers and
sailors auditorium we're gonna be
playing pub G with about a hundred other
people in real life sean has brought his
very own team here Space Station gaming
these guys are the best pub G players in
the entire world well one of them is
specifically in the rest support him
apparently Chattanooga has the fastest
internet in the entire United States or
one of the fastest internet connections
as the name 10-gig a hundred players
playing pub G all at the same time it's
a great way to show off
exactly how fast that internet is it's
nice to imagine that most people here
are pretty good this game if it's just
me and Sam and like I guess you and
Shawn probably gonna do pretty mediocre
no offense but if we split up the
protein we get two and two I think we'll
be in the top ten of around every
station here has four computers on it
because this is squad based gameplay and
they each have their own themes and I
really wanted to go on this one there's
Lord of the Rings so we got Sam wise
over there this is the Four Horsemen of
the Apocalypse and when you're playing
pub gee there's no greater horseman then
Dan Witten bought a waterproof stretch
fabric heavy-duty trash bag genk way to
go but Jane can work in events this is
just a t-shirt which is easily different
straight a bowl before I dump a bunch of
sand on the floor
I want to sweep up it's very important
keep it workspace clean because you
don't want what you're working on to get
dirty with a previous works mess to
organization you know where all your
tools are three just safety like sawdust
is slippery and it's just nicer to be me
tonight and when I sweep up the sand
after we dump it on the floor I don't
want to have all the sawdust mixed in
because I'd like to reuse the sand
during the testing god bless him put
some sand on top and then it's an okay
test uh-huh it's a little bit smaller
than a human head that's cool yeah works
pretty well but I feel like this is
pretty promising
time to move out of the full skill pros
alright alright now I get to clean this
really high pressure for us because
right now weird we're sitting next to
one of the best pub G squads world no
idea how we're gonna hold up to that
there the boat going up here me go why
are you stopping here then we're going
to the back I'm dead
holy crap I thought we're going to the
back of Ireland we had different plans
someone stay up is anyone still like
like we're all goats on it like cliffs I
shot people without killing people I
think in a game this is the full-scale
test we came up with the cloth being the
best and now we've brought it to scale
at 3 feet by 3 feet I wanted him to
approve the look and also have some fun
by covering me in sand because I'm the
type of man when I make a machine I put
myself in it for a test the actor I'll
be under here and then they get their
head in place then we're gonna cover it
and I'll watch your eyes ok there's a
little bit there's a gap here and you
get here ok I'm wondering if you do like
a plus shape to slip thought I'd be more
effective yeah alright this time it's
gonna go over the front in the back ok
so heads up
yes yeah there we go
I think you might be right I think
a-plus we might have to make an
adjustment on that three two one go
[Music]
that's pretty good that's pretty good
more time that looks really good
nice I've been saying this we all know
if it's true but we're gonna keep saying
it this is probably the most connected
facility in the world dedicated the
wireless per diem time we see people
struggled like even get one computer
with streaming properly sometimes so I'm
just super impressed we did really
really really well after the first game
she's out of the bowl now so it's it's
it's it's all up to her to kind of find
a spa all this individual to find a spot
that can get both players but two V ones
are very winnable given good positioning
Elise what if the teams we get wiped out
like our team dies pretty quickly so
just Sam Nick and then the two pro
gamers a team of Nick myself Smurf and D
master two of them get wiped out it's
just Nick your screen is I believe it's
famine following war there we've got
look at the rest of the people who are
out are gathered around there and by the
way this is Nick's like fifth game ever
playing this game here she might have
heard a footstep like I'd heard of
what's that Lauren famine again her
incredible panic and she's not looking
to her left
we've seen them hearing so oh look look
like I think war is about see her Smurfs
literally just turns the corner goes run
this guy's lattice site and just walks
right up to it right there shoot him
shoot you shoot the chest he's knocked
out oh no no it's what we would
announcements are going crazy
everybody's like bated breath waiting to
see what happens is the last is one on
one one on one is up tune in
the guidance the game oh no no it's one
me one it's a one-to-one situation
doesn't know though if Nick wins this
game just Isis this other guy I want to
clarify something you did this no like
this congratulations first of all how do
you like it out there it was great so
this is your first day playing pub G at
all
I played a little bit yesterday Oh guys
just warming up okay awesome who you are
day two winning it was the ultimate rags
to riches story because literally
yesterday I watched his first game ever
and now look at him he's a champion
[Music]